federica et jimmy bonjour madame
monsieur bonjour l'invité de 5 à 10 ce
matin lidge à beaulieu vous est la
référente de la république en marche en
martinique
madame beaulieu bonjour éditeurs hier
encore un homme a été tué cela fait
dix-sept morts depuis le début de
l'année dont 14 par arme à feu et depuis
le mois de juillet il n'y a environ 1
morts par semaine
quel regard jetez vous sur cette
situation c'est une situation qui
évidemment est dramatique est
particulièrement préoccupante à la fois
pour la population qui se sent en
insécurité c'est légitime mais surtout
pour les forces de l'ordre qui ont qui
doit faire face à une violence de plus
en plus comment dirais-je
impressionnante sachant que ont commencé
à leur tirer dessus
voilà tout à fait encore hier des forces
de l'ordre qui ont subi un caillassage
en règle à l'enjeu le dit bellevue
oui c'est un souci et je pense aussi
qu'il ya un souci entre guillemets
sociétal puisque on accorde pas
suffisamment d'importance à une vie
humaine sous prétexte qu elle est entre
guillemets caché par un uniforme
on oublie que c'est ce sont des hommes
des femmes comme vous et moi qui ont
choisi de protéger la population et ça
devrait être respectée parce que c'est
un engagement particulièrement noble on
ne respecte plus rien à faire quand je
dis on ne respecte plus rien même les
pompiers qui viennent au secours belges
suisses et cc c'est vraiment une
difficulté mais ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas spécifique à lamartine et
malheureusement je crois que il ya
quelque chose à repenser dans notre
modèle sociétal
alors bon c'est particulièrement
ambitieux parce que quand je viens de
vous le dire c'est pas spécifique à la
martinique
mais on peut se contenter déjà de
commencer par le petit pays qui est le
nôtre que nous adorons tous et rappeler
aux gens que il y a des principes de vie
pour une vie dans une île magnifique une
île comme beaucoup de personnes nous en
vivre beaucoup voudraient
vivre ici donc il faut respecter les uns
et les autres il faut que nous
réapprenions à vivre ensemble et cette
violence qui est souvent qui émane de la
jeunesse une jeunesse à laquelle il nous
faut apporter des réponses est l'une des
réponses et leur apporter des
perspectives d'avenir et je crois que ça
manque un peu puisque c'est une jeunesse
qui a du mal à se projeter
il vit dans l'instant présent d'où le
peu d'importance qu'elles accordent aux
visuels une situation grave qui ne
semble pas mobiliser le gouvernement
pouvoir intéresser le gouvernement
comment percevez vous le fait que les
partenaires parlent peu les
parlementaires pardon demande des
mesures d'urgence pour lutter contre
cette violence il n'y a aucune réponse
du gouvernement alors il n'est pas il
n'est pas vrai qu'il n'ya aucune réponse
puisque il me semble que la députée man
a fait un courrier que vous supposez
nous soutenaient de la réponse qui a été
donnée au gouvernement par le
gouvernement je ne me souviens pas
précisément des termes de la réponse
mais il est clair que de toute façon
la problématique est prise en compte moi
même je me suis assuré de faire remonter
les inquiétudes et l'urgence d'avoir des
réponses j'ai bon espoir eu des
décisions seront prises
j'espère prochainement est ce qu'il ya
une forme de mépris que la queue que du
fait que alors que l'on demande aux
parlementaires de se rapprocher encore
du ministre d outre mer et que kylie pas
de plan précis d'actions alors le début
de mois quand même oui mais le
gouvernement actuel rappelons le est un
gouvernement qui prend des décisions
basées sur des concertations
les parlementaires ont soulevé des
problématiques
il nous faut aussi nous faire des
propositions qui soient évalués il
paraît évidente
des effectifs supplémentaires pour
renforcer les forces de l'ordre serait
une solution
mais il ne faut pas il ne faut pas se
baser faut pas baser nos raisonnements
sur des évidences
c'est ce qu'il faut faire comme les 500
frères en guyane sont alors tout dépend
de ce que vous appelez faire comme les
500 frères se sont mobilisés pour quand
on a le sentiment de ne pas être
entendus c'est légitime mais il ne
suffit pas de se mobiliser pour être
crédible il faut faire des propositions
concrètes autre type de violence celle
faite aux femmes les violences
conjugales chaque jour trois femmes
battues par dépose plainte en martinique
c'est un chiffre effrayant
oui oui c'est oui oui il faut qu'il faut
lutter contre sa main de toute façon là
en ce moment là toute une campagne sur
notamment le 39 19
pour justement libérer la parole faire
libérer aussi la culpabilité que peuvent
ressentir certaines femmes de se
retrouver dans une situation où elles
ont le sentiment de d'être partie
prenante alors qu'en fait elles sont
réellement des victimes
peu importe les raisons pour lesquelles
on est dans dans une dans une situation
où on y ont frappé par son conjoint
on est une victime rien ne justifie la
violence physique qu'en qualité de
responsable politique quelle proposition
vous pouvez vous faire vous madame
beaulieu déjà ce qui est en train d'être
fait c'est à dire sensibiliser les
mentalités sensibiliser la population
rappeler que ces situations auxquelles
finalement on s'est habitués ne sont pas
des situations normales que dans un
couple
le on a le droit de se disputer mais on
n'a pas le droit de ceux de se frapper
physiquement ça la la la la violence
physique de toute façon c'est un aveu de
nos arguments il ya des jeunes donc lui
a eu le lancement des gros
du grenelle des violences conjugales has
la mise en en place ici de la commission
territoriale de lutte mais se pose aussi
la question des moyens les moyens pour
d'action quelles que soient les
problématiques que nous rencontrons
avec la majorité actuelle étant donné
qu'on récupère parfois plusieurs
décennies de mauvaises décisions voire
non décision tout ce qu'on veut faire
il ya la problématique financière c'est
clair mais moi je préfère retenir le
fait qu' il y a une volonté qui est
manifestée ce que ce fameux grenelle
je n'ai pas connaissance qu'ils aient eu
lieu auparavant
donc pour moi c'est déjà un très grand
pas en avant
de sensibiliser la population
sensibiliser les élus sensibiliser tous
les acteurs et ensuite évidemment la
question du financement sera sans doute
plus facile à régler
si les gens prennent conscience qu'il y
avait véritablement un problème
d'importance alors parlons politique que
maintenant vous est la référente dans
marge pour la martinique depuis le 7 mai
vous n'aviez pas encore installé votre
équipe c'est chose faite maintenant
alors j j'ai une petite équipe autour de
moi qui aura vocation bien sûr au fil
des mois à s'étoffer
oui donc on va pouvoir commencer notre
travail de fond que ses équipes une
équipe que j'aurai l'occasion de
présenter lors de notre rentrée
politique
alors la date est pas encore bien
arrêtée ce sera le 5 et où le 6 octobre
alors quelles seront vos orientations
votre objectif nos orientations notre
objectif par rapport à quoi
par rapport à déjà papou pour le pour le
mouvement que vous représentez qu'un
mouvement jeu d'accord alors pour le
mouvement
comment j'allais déjà dit restructurer
remobiliser acquérir de la crédibilité
de la visibilité la visibilité aussi
tout ceci fera partie de toutes les
annonces que nous ferons lors de notre
rentrée nous avons à coeur aussi 2
rallier entre guillemets les jeunes il
faut qu'ils se saisissent de la chose
politique puisque c'est aussi de leur
avenir dont il est question et nous
voulons aussi mobiliser l'engagement
politique des femmes et parce que
j'estime que si nous arrivons à
remobiliser les jeunes et à mobiliser
les femmes ça va forcément aboutir à un
renouvellement qui est latente de nos
concitoyens comment cela va se traduire
pour vous sur votre stratégie pour l'ue
municipal pour les municipales on vient
on va on va quand je vous ai dit on est
à la recherche de candidatures féminines
je vais en profiter pour lancer un appel
et c'est vraiment c'est pas c'est pas
seulement en martinique
c'est vraiment l'esprit du mouvement on
veut atteindre la parité au sein des
cadres du mouvement d'ici 2020 donc il y
a urgence pour nous de trouver des
figures féminines qui accepte de porter
nos valeurs alors il ya environ une
quinzaine de comités en martinique
vous allez présenter des candidats ou
des candidates sur chaque comité dans
chaque dans chaque commune où il ya des
qualités dans chaque commune ce sera
particulièrement ambitieux dans chaque
comité
pourquoi pas ce sera je pense quand même
qu'il faudra qu'on se concerte avec les
animateurs ce sera à eux de de faire
émerger les candidatures mais je répète
il n'est pas question de se présenter
juste pour se présenter si le maire en
place se représenter que a priori il n'y
a pas de raison de penser qu'il fait du
mauvais travail je vois pas pourquoi on
va lui mettre des bâtons dans lions et
vous serez candidate à saint joseph
alors ma candidature est une question
posée à laquelle il faudra effectivement
statut et madame nomination tardive a
décalé le planning donc tous les
dossiers justement sur les municipales
seront traitées tour durant le courant
du mois de septembre
d'accord mais vous êtes en pourparlers
avec la députée manager de rayon
pourparlers sur grand mot on est en
contact
ne l'oubliez pas de vous retrouver sur
une liste commune
ça ça doit se discuter ce n'est pas à
moi de décider si la dame on désire et
candidate c'est à elle de gérer sa liste
si elles souhaitent ma participation on
en discutera voilà je vous ai dit tout
c'est toutes ces problématiques seront
débattus durant le mois de septembre
alors j'ai bien compris h el cheikh il
ya un candidat que vous pouvez soutenir
on parle souvent de monsieur daniel
chomet alors monsieur chômeurs
à fait partie des soutiens de la liste
renaissance en marche pour l'europe
donc il s'éteint c'est un écologiste
convaincu
donc il a un profil effectivement qui
pourraient nous intéresser mais
investiture comme soutien ne sont pas
imposés aux candidats
il faut qu'ils en fassent la demande en
gaz du lot un petit souci un petit souci
oui et non nos candidatures enfin nous
avons un allié historique qui est le
modem est donc
monsieur monsieur reif montplaisir qui
est marcheurs qui est le maire en place
a dans son opposition au nombre des
membres du modem dont classe et on va
pas forcément dire que c'est une
situation qui était présente à notre
mouvement mais qu'il faudra régler
oui mais on peut régler les situations
en bonne intelligence sans pour autant
se faire la guerre est ce que c'est
envisageable d'avoir un marcheur et un
modem en face à un marcheur demandiez
demander ce que ce qu'on pense les
bordelais c'est le cas à bordeaux
donc pour une petite ville comme keynes
pilote je ne vois pas en quoi ce serait
particulièrement un homme les les
candidatures il n'y a pas de mot d'ordre
national c'est au cas par cas et là il
ya une situation qui préexistait on va
pas non plus imposer aux gens de faire
autrement que ce qu'ils avaient prévu
avant même notre existence
madame beaulieu je vous remercie bonne
journée à l'écouté de nos programmes
parfois à voir